It's important to note that the research
you conduct with your prototype
doesn't have to be complicated,
but it does have to be effective.
To be effective,
your research needs to answer whatever
questions you ask at the beginning.
This was a great insight shared by Tomer
Sharon in the product design course.
So what questions are those?
The stage or fidelity your prototype is
in will determine the type of feedback
you ask for and
the type of questions you ask.
First, it's easier to get good
information from qualitative questions
rather than quantitative questions.
For example, if you're presenting
a low fidelity prototype,
you're probably just going to want
to ask very high level questions,
such as, can a user easily learn and
use this app?
However, if you're presenting
a prototype that includes
microinteractions and is reflective of
the finished product, you'll probably
want to ask questions such as,
how does this animation feel to you?
Do the interactions get in the way of or
improve the experience?
Your goals are entirely different at
that stage since you're moving to more
of a finished product.
I've put a list of useful
questions to ask and answer for
each kind of prototype in
the instruction notes below the video.
These questions will get you feedback.
Valuable feedback is any
feedback that combines a specific
part of the prototype.
With a positive or negative
feeling on the part of the user.
For instance,
a user reporting that they are confused
by the menu is very valuable feedback,
as is a user being excited at how
quickly they can achieve their goal.
Specific suggestions can be helpful
feedback, but are often not useful until
you're working on very
high fidelity prototypes.
When you're first
recording users' feedback,
make sure to keep all
of it that you can.
We'll talk later on about how
to go about doing this, and
about what permission you
need from your users.
At the end of the lesson,
you'll be looking for
patterns in the feedback from
various users on the same prototype.
So detailed records are vital.